Các đầy tảm người nằm ngày 1 2 tháng chính,
nằm 1 nhìn chính trăm 1 mề lầm tại khoảng trường bà đình
chủ tịch hồ chi Minh, tóc bản tuyên ngôn đập lập
hai xin ra nước Việt Nam sân chủ cộng hoa,
mở ra kỷ huên phát triển mới, kỷ huên đập lập xân tóc
cắn liền với chủ hiếp xá hội.
Bản tuyên ngôn đập lập nắn gọn,
nhưng chữa được những lỗi dùng bất hủ không chỉ có giá chị lịch sử
lối vây xân tóc Việt Nam,
mặt con có ý nghĩa thời gại xấu sắc.
Ngày 2 tháng tảm, nằm 1 nhìn chính trăm 1 mề lầm
hồ chi Minh dời tân trào về hà nội.
Ngày 2 mề lầm tháng tảm, nằm 1 nhìn chính trăm 1 mề lầm
hồ chi Minh cùng quy phán sân tóc xải phóng về đến hà nội.
Người ở tạng nhà số 1 mề lầm, hẳn ngàn,
của nhà tư sản sân tóc trịt văn bộ.
Đêm 2 mề lầm tháng tảm nằm 1 nhìn chính trăm 1 mề lầm
chủ tịch chính phủ lâm thời Việt Nam xanh chủ cộng hoa,
hồ chi Minh khởi thảo bản tư nôn đập lập,
đại nhà số 1 mề lầm hà nàng.
Ngày 3 mề mốt tháng tảm nằm 1 mề lầm
chủ tịch hồ chi Minh đặc lại bộ xung 1 số điểm
vào bản thảo tư nôn đập lập.
Châu ngày 1 2 tháng chính nằm 1 nhìn chính trăm 1 mề lầm,
chủ tịch chính phủ lâm thời hồ chi Minh đặc tư nôn đập lập
hài xin sản nước Việt Nam xanh chủ cộng hoa.
chính phủ lâm thời xảm mắt quốc xanh đồng bảo
ngày 1 2 tháng chính nằm 1 nhìn chính trăm 1 mề lầm.
1 hồ chi Minh chuột tịch chính phủ lâm thời gian bộ trưởng rại dào.
Hài khoảng 1 xác mộ trưởng lội vụ,
bà trần rư lượng bộ trưởng thông tin trình trình.
Bốn trù văn tánh bộ trưởng quốc phòng,
nằm xương tức hiện bộ trưởng thanh miền,
sấu 1 mạnh hà bộ trưởng tình tế quốc xa.
Bày 1 mềm bản tố bộ trưởng gú tế xa hội,
tảm bố trọng hánh bộ trưởng tư pháp,
chính phạm ngọc hại bộ trưởng y tế.
Mời tạo trọng khiến bộ trưởng sau thông công chính,
mề mộ lề văn hiến bộ trưởng lào đầu,
mề hài phạm đồng bộ trưởng tài chính,
mề bà vô định ngoài bộ trưởng quốc xa sáo dục,
mề bốn cù viết cộng bộ trưởng không giữ bộ nào.
Mề lâm, mề phản xuân bộ trưởng không giữ bộ nào.
Từ sáng sớm, cà hà nội nảo nhật trong mâu cơ đó sau văn phát đèn hoa xức rớt,
những việc tận lớn bằng chữ việt pháp ngà anh Trung Quốc
chẳng khắp các đường phố, nước Việt Nam của người Việt Nam,
lột lập hay là chết,
ủng hộ chính phủ lâm thời, ủng hộ chủ tịch hồ chỉ mấyng.
Môn chợ trái tim hồi hộp hướng về hà nội,
trở đợi xây cuối thiên liên nhật.
Đúng mề bốn dờ, ngày 1 2 tháng chính,
chủ tịch hồ chỉ mấyng, công các thành viên trong chính phủ lâm thời,
bước dả lễ đại,
bà nhạc đến quân cah phùm chẳng phát lên,
mọi em mắt đều hướng về lát gở đó sau văn dịch sữa
tư từ được kéo lên theo nghiệp điều của bài hát.
Trong không tí trang nghiêm,
chủ tịch hồ chỉ mấyng, chẳng chọng là phản thân luôn tập lập lix sử,
quyết bố với phản thệ nhân dành với thế giới,
Việt Nam sân chủ tộng hoa tập lập tự gió xà đời.
Hi đúng bào cá nước,
tất cả mọi người điều xinh ra khô quyền bị đáng,
tạo qua cho hồ những quyền không ai có thể xam phản lực.
Công những quyền ấy có quyền lực xấu,
quyền thực dọ và quyền mưu cầu hạnh thúc.
Lời bất hủ ấy,
ở trong bản thân luôn lập năm một nghiệp bài chăm bài mưu xấu của nước Mỹ.
Fui rộng ra,
cầu ấy có ý nghĩa là,
rất cả các nhân tục tinh thế giới,
điều xinh ra mình đẳng,
giân tục nào,
không có quyền xấu,
quyền chúng xuống,
và quyền thực dọng.
Bản quyền mưu xấu,
nhân quyền và nhân quyền của cách mạng phát,
năm một nghiệp bài chăm tinh như một cũng nói.
Nguyên đòi xinh ra từ giới và bên đáng,
về quyền lời,
và phải luôn luôn được từ giới và bên đáng về quyền lời.
Đó là những lẽ phải không ai chối trái được.
Nước Việt Nam có quyền hưởng từ giới và được lập,
và sự thích đã thành một nước từ giới độc lập.
Bản thị ím thậu Việt Nam quyết năm tất cả tính thành bà lực lượng,
tính mạng và của gái để giữ hướng quyền từ giới độc lập ấy.
Bản quyền mưu độc lập là phát triển lịch sử phô giá,
kết thình thử lợi của cuộc nấu tranh sải hóng xân tộc của nhân dân ta,
hội tụt tâm nghiệp chỉ tự thật phô chiming,
là bản cùng cả mơ đầu tiên quyền mới của sân tộc Việt Nam
khi quyền tộc lập tự gió.
Tự vột sân tộc Việt ngôn lệ lập thàn,
Việt Nam đã giúp bồn đứng sạch sáng rạc,
tánh hắng chủ nghiệp thực sân cú phá mới,
quan thành tất cả mạng sân tộc sân chủ nhân dân,
hấm nhất ở quốc, được cả nước đi lên chủ nghiệp xá hội.
Đó là những mình chứng hùng hồn Facebook mạng cửa chân liếng,
không có gì quy hơn tộc lập tự gió.
Tấm với năm đã trời qua,
tên nôn được lập vẫn mang sức sống mạnh liệt và giá chịt trên tôn.
Lạnh họ được soit đường cho sự nghiệp xây dân và bảo vệ tộ quốc Việt Nam
sau hội chủ nghiệp.
Chưa bao giờ, rất nước ta có được cơ đồ,
điểm lực, vịh hế và vịh tým xóc tế như ngày này.
Tạo giá hế và lực, cho rất nước tiếp tục đi lên với những trên bảo tốt nè.